help me leave porn and build something
better for myself and use my experiences
what I went through to help people and
not judge people I'm not juding you I
totally feel judged um but that's okay
that's me is that because you don't want
is that because you don't want any
accountability is that why you don't
want to be judged excuse me you don't
want to hold any accountability like
most wom I do hold accountability so why
don't you want to be judged because
being a judge on that because what she's
saying is incorrect about how I feel and
what I went through if anything all I
hear is how I feel how I feel how I feel
I don't hear logic here you have no
logic because you misunderstood the
words that came out my mouth originally
well people who have a lot of sex with
different people are bipolar so they
switch up on you um no you're just a
idiot because you misunderstood
anything but an idiot